I have a friend that had his own
business for a long time, and
he didn't have any co-founder and
he made a lot of money.
But one day, he had a new idea and
he decided to start a new company and
this time with a co-founder.
That was also a co-founder before,
and when they started collaborating,
it was amazing.
All of a sudden they build
the business that grew so
fast that it diminished
everything they did before, and
that's my personal opinion,
that it's natural to have a co-founder.
But they prove themselves
as sole founders before and
they were very successful before that so
everything is possible.
I believe that someone who wants
to do his own business by himself,
he definitely can do it.
He's probably more loner person.
Thus, they prefer to walk along and
trust mainly on himself.
It's a different, it's a different
social structure, it's a different
personality and I know a lot of
successful people that did just that.
All people had co-founders
that are not as
Dominant as them or not not as
important in the company as them.
They have much more A type personality
and they did amazingly well also.
Everybody can succeed
there's no right or wrong.
That's my personal preference.